toyotaro the Artis and writer behind
Dragon Ball Su manga recently posted up
a video of him drawing some promo art
for the Dragon Ball Legend stuff and it
is wild to see just how much you can
learn from this speed drawing like first
of all in the video you can see him
referencing his own hand as well as
pictures of hands from Google for
reference there's nothing wrong with
that and you could never be too good for
reference or the fact that I somehow
never realize Toyota Taro is left-handed
but probably my favorite part of this
video is just comparing it to a similar
video of Toriyama doing a smaller
promotional sketch back in the day
putting them side by side just really
illuminates how different of an artist
these two are obviously the
circumstances are different toyos is for
a big promo event and Toriyama is just a
sketch but even then the incredible
fluency and effortless nature of
toriyama's Mastery is just wild to see
by comparison it makes me so happy that
toyotaro is studying under him with each
passing year his understanding of art
composition an anomy Etc has all
improved under Toriyama and I am happy
for him to the point of immense jealousy